اعتمد ولي العهد السعوديه الامير محمد بن
سلمان التوجه التنموي لجزيره دارين وتروت
كما وافق ايضا على انشاء مؤسسه لتطوير
جزيره دارين وتروت بميزانيه تقديريه بلغت
نحو مليارين و600 مليون ريال وتمتد
الجزيره السعوديه على مساحه 32 كم مربعا
ويقطونها 120,000 سنه
الامير احمد بن فهد نائب امير المنطقه
الشرقيه نائب رئيس مجلس الاداره ورئيس
اللجنه التنفيذيه لهيئه تطوير المنطقه
الشرقيه اسمه الامير مرحبا بك معي في
نشرته الرابعه من الرياض بدايتها كيف
تقراون هذا همم
اعتماد لتوجه التنموي لجزيره دارين وتاروت
من ولي العهد الامير محمد بن سلمان
اولا الحمد لله على ما تحفظ هذه البلاد من
فضله وخير والنعم كثيره
وتشرف بانها ارفع المقام مولاي خالد
المحرمه الشريفين والسمو السيد ولي العهد
الامين حفظه الله العظيم الشكر والامتنان
ااا ما بشكرون قرار الكريم باعتماد التوجه
التنموي للجزيره التعليم وتاروت رؤيه
العهد سوف ينعكس بشكل ايجابي ان شاء الله
على الجانب الاقتصادي للمنطقه وهو يعكس
بشكل
سيدي ولي العهد حفظه الله على التنميه
الشامله بحيث تشمل كل مدينه وقريه في
المملكه
مع التركيز على الاستفاده من المميزات
النسبيه لكل منطقه والعمل بشكل استراتيجي
منظم لاستقرار وتحفيظ الاستثمار ورفع جوده
الحياه همم
السكان المملكه
وهذا واضح الحقيقه من قارات انشاء الهيئات
التنمويه مثل هيئه تطوير المنطقه الشرقيه
وهي التطوير منطقه هيئه تطوير الاحساء
والحقيقه انه ما نشاهدها اليوم هي واحده
من مبادرات الاستراتيجيه التي عملت عليها
هيئه تطوير المنطقه الشرقيه
وتم التركيز فيها على ثلاث محاور رئيسيه
اولها المحافظه على الجانب الثقافي
والتراثي للمركان اضافه الى حمايه
والتفعيل المواقع الطبيعيه والبيئيه وبدها
شكل المحور الثالث والتفعيل دور الجزيره
في تعزيز الاقتصاد السياحي والاصدقائي
بجوده الحياه
والحمد لله خلال السنتين ماضيه كان العمل
مستمر على انتهاء المزحات والدراسات
البيئيه والاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه وغيرها
والهيئه باذن الله استقبل العمل مع
شركاءها في مختلف القطاعات على هذه
المبادره استراتيجيه يضافه الى مبادرات
اخرى باذن الله عمل كبير ويمكن حتى طويل
سمو الامير حتى اقرار هذا الاعتماد لكن
خليني اسال ايضا عن الى اي درجه يمكن ان
تسهم طبعا هذه المؤسسه المؤسسه التطوير
جزيره دارين وتاروت في انها تطور تغير
تحدد ايضا في هذه الجزيره الجزيره دارين
وتاروت
ايه المؤسسه
التطوير جزيره دارين تاروت مؤسسه غير طبعا
وهي خطوه غير مسبوقه في تاريخ التنميه في
المنطقه الشرقيه
واجابه على سؤالك تم تخصيص مليارين و600
و 44 مليون ريال كاجمالي تكاليف الجزيره
لان سنه باذن الله 2030
ايضا سوف يتم نقل الانشطه الصناعيه خارج
دارين وتاروت وحصل على مصالح الاهالي
المنطقه والمستثمرين راح تتولى امانه
المنطقه الشرقيه هذا الملف بحسب الاجراءات
المتبعه بما يحفظ حقوق الناس جميعا
وما في شك ان المبادره تضمنت عدد مشاريع
جديده في قطاعات مختلفه واللي تتحقق باذن
الله هلا في الوظائف لابناء المنطقه
الشرقيه وبالاخص هذه
نقطه مهمه سمو الامير اكثر من مره في
اجاباتك علينا ان همم الاثر الاقتصادي
لتاسيس هذه المؤسسه المؤسسه التطبيب دارين
جزيره دارين وتاروت كيف يمكن الحديث عنها
سمو الامير بشكل
والله الحقيقه الدراسات العملات تشيرن
المبادره سوف تتحقق باذن الله اجر اقتصادي
واجتماعي كبير في مساهمه هذه المبادره في
الناتج الاجمالي المحلي حسب الدراسه
ستكون
همم يصل الى
2077 مليون ريال سنويا مع تقديرات متوقعه
يعني الوظائف باذن الله اكثر من 100,000
همم فرصه عمل في الجانب السياحي اللي هو
ايضا مهم جدا همم متوقع ان يصل اجمالي
الزوار والسائحين للجزيره الى مليون
و300,000 سائح بحلول 20 30 ان شاء الله
وان شاء الله بتشهد المنطقه الشرقيه بحول
الله عدد المبادرات والمشاريع النوعيه من
خلال هيئه تطوير المنطقه الشرقيه وهي
تطوير الاحزاب والشراسه مع جهاد اخرى من
قطاعين العام والخاص
الاقتصادي كبير وارقام مبهره ايضا سمو
الامير انا اشكرك جزيل الشكر
لانضمامك الينا كان مع الهاتفيا الامير
احمد بن فهد نائب وامير المنطقه الشرقيه
نائب رئيس مجلس الاداره ورئيس اللجنه
التنفيذيه لهيئه تطوير المنطقه الشرقيه